one of the factors that derail our
decisions that has to do with forces
from our relationships is due to social
comparisons now since we are human
beings whenever we try to evaluate
ourselves on several dimensions from a
good we are as decision-maker to how
good we are at solving problems or how
creative we are we look at others our
peers colleagues and friends in order to
evaluate ourselves but those type of
social comparisons can come in the way
when we are implementing our plans so
for example there is some really
interesting research coming out of
calleb showing the following imagine
you're an mba students who graduated
recently and you're considering
different job offers the first offer is
with a company that you really like and
the job is for a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars a year this is your
base salary and you know that your peers
people graduated from your own program
are also offered the similar jobs for
the same compensation one hundred and
fifty thousand dollars now there is a
second job offer that you're considering
and it's one where this time you'll be
joining a different company but it's
also a company that you very much like
and the salary is a little bit higher is
a hundred and seventy five thousand
dollars so twenty five thousand dollars
higher than the previous one but this
time you know that other people like you
so peers and graduates from your same
program are being offered similar jobs
for a hundred and eighty five thousand
dollars what the data suggests is that
if you were presented with this
situation you would tend to choose the
first job the one that has a lower
salary and the reason is that the social
comparison that is triggered by the
second job is making you feel uneasy and
so you rather go with a job that pays
less but knowing that you fare as well
when comparing yourself to your peers so
social comparison can really come in the
way of good decision making and can be
realized as we implement our plans so
what should we do about that
once again the solution is in a sense
intuitive but difficult to apply as
we're making decision we should ask
ourselves questions about the
information that we are using to make
those decisions and whether it's
information about ourselves only or
social-comparison are tricking in and
affecting the way we're thinking about
the problem or the decision itself